we got some major major news out of
Italy over the weekend over the last
couple days here's a quote from the
daily wire Georgia Maloney claimed
Victory early Monday morning and is
projected to win a battle to become
Italy's first female prime minister
leading her conservative party Brothers
of Italy in the country's national
elections okay now first off she's a
woman
she's a woman I think she uses women
pronouns she's chick boobs the whole
thing uh now generally speaking the
lefties and the progressives and you
know all these people they love women so
you'd think they'd be very excited about
this but no no no she's scary she's a
conservative we've got two clips of
Maloney giving a speech about why she
ran what she believes in and what she
wants to do to Italy this first one is
absolutely phenomenal foreign
familiar
perfect
I love it it's so good she's the telling
the truth you know what I must say and
guys you get it you get it so here is a
western democracy now a lot of this
stuff has been happening in some of the
Eastern countries in Europe Eastern
European countries but here's a Western
European democracy that has had enough
of the wokeness it has had enough of
collectivism it has had enough of people
being defined by their gender or their
other immutable characteristics it it's
had enough of you saying that your kids
are born boys but they're actually girls
The Assault on religion The Assault on
all of our institutions this is a
phenomenal speech so of course everyone
in the western media is calling her a
fascist and and even worse than that uh
here are uh here's a little video of her
being called a fascist because you know
she believes in the individual which I
thought was the basis of Western
Civilization voters in Italy tomorrow
are pure Poise to make a hard right turn
the woman expected to become Prime
Minister leads a party with roots in
neo-fascism the Hallmarks of Italian
fascism like this motto
God Fatherland and family they far-right
political party whose roots go back to
post World War II neo-fascists most
far-right government in that country
since Mussolini most right-wing
government since Mussolini since
Mussolini the media has no problem lying
to you about everything and everyone if
they don't bow to the narrative so why
are they freaking out about her well we
showed you a little bit of it before but
she continued defending nationalism
defending individual freedom and the
right for Italians to set what the
Italian agenda is going to be like
foreign
foreign
quoting Chesterton defending truth